good morning John I am Hank and this is
Hank sock a sock version of me hello and
the Hank sock and I are here to tell you
some very exciting news I guess a couple
of months ago John and I decided that we
were really interested in the
possibility of getting a real life
online video conference in order to get
all of the best online video creators
together in the same place and the
communities that support those groups in
order to get like an entire epic
gigantic weekend of fun and growing the
community and doing awesome things
m'angil big news yeah that's that's mine
I mean the news is that we're actually
going to do it and it's gonna be this
summer in Los Angeles from July 9th to
July 11th your big news is that a bunch
of you and your nerdy friends are gonna
get together a drink juicy juices hang
out and talk about nerdy stuff
I mean haengsuk I don't think that you
understand that online video is is like
a really huge deal well I got a to grow
toe Dale that's a really huge deal but
I'm not gonna convert about it um having
a really hard time figuring out how you
could have a ingrown toenail well yeah
it's complicated anyway
online video is an entirely new medium
it's creating new genres and really
active engaged and large communities of
people and believe it or not they're
probably going to be like a hundred
thousand people watching this video that
we're making right now
mmm how's my hair um your hair is
surprisingly sparkly I never notice that
your hair was sparkly yeah I use product
what nothing don't worry about it John
who's gonna be there uh well a lot of
people are gonna be there people from
nerdfighteria all the way from charlie
is so cool like too easy waiter but also
people from all over the world of online
video we got Michael Buckley Dave days
shaycarl Brittani Louise Taylor ray
william johnson david choi rhettandlink
mitchell davis me my brother Julia Nunes
Natalie Tran I can't believe we have
freaking Natalie Tran shane dawson
shanedawsontv shane the success of these
of these projects isn't based on like
million dollar marketing budgets
or the ungodly beauty of the people who
started them that's my Jerry yeah thanks
it's based and what I think is the raw
ability to entertain and people who are
able to bring people into the
communities so that they watch every new
video that gets put out not just when
they light their face on fire or capture
a particularly adorable cat moment god I
love that gasps yeah I know I love that
cat too but the cat's not gonna be there
we couldn't get the gaff of the
conference but there are going to be
many of the most successful people and
online video on that list that I gave
you earlier is it even complete list and
we're going to have demonstrations and
we're gonna have talks and performances
by these people we're gonna have
concerts and dance parties and we're
gonna have all kinds of crazy things
that we can't even think of yet and
we're gonna ask the community take pur
to present ideas for us like karaoke
karaoke is a very good idea thank you
that's an excellent idea
I want to ball pit a ball pit yes a ball
pit is another great do you have other
ideas how about a booth when Charlie
McDonnell suits any white people's
fingers so that they can say out out
jolly I will talk to Charlie about that
there's going to be an insider track
that's going to be basically for people
who are really into YouTube and want to
get down on the down and dirty specifics
of creating community on YouTube in the
business and and the future of YouTube
it is going to cost money it's go the
registration is going to cost money
because these things cost a lot of money
to put on if you want to find out more
there's lots more information on the
website which is at VidCon 2010 dot-com
and you can check out our Twitter feed
at twitter.com slash VidCon and our
YouTube channel of course youtube.com
slash VidCon I think that's all I want
to talk about John nerdfighters will see
what huh